hi at Facebook fans the first time I'm
doing this on Facebook I'm really
excited but we are in the Toyota green
room with refinery29 co-founder and
executive creative director Tierra
Gilardi great to have you here this is
obviously a live interview so we're
gonna have people coming going you're
gonna hear all the backgrounds what
happens but we want to talk more about
our discussion this morning because I
think we're fine we're 29 really focused
on an issue that is prevalent throughout
society 67% of society identifies
themselves as plus size up size 14 or
larger yeah and they give maybe one or
two percent of coverage in the media
yeah that's shocking yeah it's really
shocking you know when we learned that
we were you know we were really
surprised that that great divide between
67 percent of the population being 410
of media advertising only representing
them 1 to 2 percent and you know it's
really this invisible majority that is
not you know we're leaving so many women
behind in the stories that were telling
the images that were showing and we
thought that that was really that was
really detrimental to women's confidence
and how they see themselves because you
know what we see around us and the
stories that get told
tell us what's valued in our society and
when you're not when you don't see
yourself when you don't see your story
being told we don't see image out there
it teaches you that you're not worthy
and I think that that really chips away
at people's confidence and their
feelings of self-worth and that really
when you don't see yourself represented
and you talk about subtle things like
even passing in movies right here the
supporting character it's a great role
yeah somebody funny friend about the
right time right and and even in you
know cartoons they talked about Ursula
being overweight sort of the villain is
the size 14 plus and I was the only you
know the only character as a child they
saw us as women see representing them in
the cartoons and that she's a villain
over the years we've seen Plus Size more
plus-size models really come to Fame
right and make a name for themselves and
make a name for society and those they
are representing you know I think it's
really interesting I think you know
refinery 9 we started our company to
sort of celebrate individuality and
self-expression and part of that was
really showing a diverse and inclusive
range of of women and our content and so
I think you know it's an interesting
time because also this you know Lenny no
generation has come up with social media
they're able to insert their own images
into the visual dialogue which then
broadens you know who we're seeing in
our media and social media is arguably
the media that we consume the most so I
think that's been interesting with our
seeing a conversation around body
positivity we're seeing more plus-size
models come to the forefront but there's
still a huge gap in who's being
represented and I I'm always really
surprised by it too because you know the
plus-size fashion industry itself is a
twenty billion dollar potential market
and yet most plus-size women they can't
go into a store and buy you know closing
their size they have these a huge vast
shopping deserts where there's not
that they can that they can buy they
have to go online or go to specialty
stores and I think also in media so
often been like the plus you know the
plus-size issue and they get one one
issue out of the right like we covered
it chat chat it's like you get a month
yeah but it doesn't address the issue
though how do you balance being accused
of not focusing on good health and sort
of equating being overweight with being
unhealthy how do you define overweight I
mean I know that a lot of the women who
portrayed themselves as plus-size models
and a lot of Millennials do eat balanced
meals do exercise do feel healthy but
they're not sighs - yeah well I think
you know societally we've pushed this
beauty standard that thin equates to
beautiful and there are so many women
that you know no matter how hard they
try if they worked out you know the
majority of their day every day an eight
salad for every meal like that's just
not how they're built that's just not
their body and so you know our take is
that you know unless you're a doctor and
you're specifically working with someone
you don't know what their health is and
I think it's part of our bias against
plus-sized people that we question the
health of someone based on their weight
whereas we wouldn't do that for a thin
person and so to us it's really more
about representation showing you know
the world as it really is you know
giving women you know a picture of
themselves in our content and because we
think that you know health begins with
mental health - and it's really like if
you're not selling their stuff yeah if
you're not seeing your image you know
it's perpetuating this cycle of shame
and you know if everything comes from
self self-love and feeling so for this
humans we you know our greatest desire
is to belong and so that's really what
we're focused on you know we have other
health content but we don't we don't put
weight and health together because I
think there are totally different
conversations and I think we just have a
conditioning to question Plus
wait where we wouldn't do that for
straight sized women yeah and you know
this whole week we've partnered with
refinery29 to talk about issues
pertaining to Millennials and I hosted a
panel earlier in the week with a group
of Millennials and we talked about how
Millennials don't necessarily identify
themselves with certain labels Rasim you
don't say I'm overweight you don't say
I'm petite you don't say necessarily I'm
even you know straight gay whatever it
is does this from what you're hearing
from viewers this generations you weight
and image differently than their
predecessors well I think you know there
is a real celebration of self identity
they want to see themselves reflected in
the content that they're consuming and
the brands that they're buying and they
yeah I think they are kind of defying
labels they don't want to be put in
boxes they want to be celebrated for
their uniqueness and I think you know
all people are complex all people are
imperfect all people you know so it's
really a sort of bringing those things
out and showcasing a different side of
what people naturally are which is
really like you're highlighting that
complexity and trying to not put people
into boxes you know I think even the
term plus-size is you know one that I
wish we could get rid of but for that
everyday and it's it's I I do think
though there is some sort of shift you
know you talk about especially high-end
designers that cater to sample sale
you know sample size models and and you
know really fitting to their bodies most
people are not a size 2 or a size zero
and it's interesting that the number one
you know area of retail where you are
seeing growth is an active we're right
people are really dressing to be
comfortable and you can make active wear
attractive enough to wear to work and
what happy but people are really
focusing on their own comfort and how
they feel as opposed to trying to fit a
mold of a certain rule book or brand I
that's good yeah yeah I think it's a new
shift and I think Millennials sometimes
get dinged for being selfish or being so
you know like yeah more self-absorbed
and I think what we are seeing is a
generation that is more cognizant of
their their health their well-being
balance in their lives and really
forging their own paths not feeling like
they there's like one direct line that
they have to follow but kind of wanting
to find their their own way we we talk
about our audiences are determined
dreamers because I think that you know
we see this generation that that does
want the space to dream to create their
own path to follow their passions but
they're hustlers they're you know
they're fine they're finding the way to
get there yeah and they're setting you
know different standards to I read four
five or 21 daily I'm a loyal follower
and I have to tell you there have been a
couple of clothing items a couple of
articles that really stood out to me
that I bought that out trends and I you
know hadn't heard about that I'm like oh
my goodness this really makes sense and
it's coming from younger generation
right so as much as they can learn from
oh yeah we can learn from Millennials oh
yeah oh yeah I think it's a mindset you
know it's my mindset more than a
generation and to me that mindset is
about wanting to grow and learn and
progress in your life and to be yourself
and to change I mean you think about
that 67 percent and yet they're giving
one to two percent you have the
attention that that's not gonna be a
business model means forget from a
society standpoint from a business
standpoint it's not sustainable no it's
not you know I think that it's the most
diverse generation in US history they
want you know it's also a very values
driven chopper where you know as
consumers want to see their values
represented by the brands that they're
buying from and so I think that brands
that aren't addressing the
sighs market that aren't you know
addressing diverse consumer base are
gonna get left behind because you know
Millennials are also a huge financial
power so they've got the power of the
purse they've got their phones it got
their credit cards on their phones their
smartphones and they know what they want
me oh I forget them they know what they
don't like
they're great to have you off the show
after the show in the Toyota greenroom
and thank you all Facebook for watching
thank you